hello everyone and welcome to the final
game we'll be showing from the pen
ultimate round of this year's Tata Ste
Masters it is vid Gujarati versus NRE
abdat and notb went into this round as
the leader of the tournament so if he
draws this or gets a win here with the
black pieces he is well on his way to
winning the Tata still Masters but it's
going to be hard he's facing a candidate
here in the form of vidit Gujarati who
is uh still undefeated in the tournament
one of the few that that are undefeated
only vidit and Prague uh so let's see
what happened here you've seen what
happened in the other runs you've seen
how ala defeated nepo Anish defeated
Jordan after that brutal blunder guesh
with the heartbreaking repetition of
moves on move 40 upon reaching time
control in a completely winning position
big heartbreak for gkes but still
anything can happen in the final round
but now let's see this one as vid does
face the leader of the tournament uh
Pawn to D4 uh we have Knight to F6 uh uh
Pawn to C4 uh we have Pawn to E six and
now uh Knight to F3 uh sorry the
interface is um giving me some issues
let me just fix that a little bit uh
yeah Knight to F3 and pawn to D5 so a
standard Queen's Gambit declined is on
the board uh we have Knight to C3 and
now Bishop to B4 uh the rag go in
defense we have Pawn to E3 castles and
Bishop to D2 uh we have Pawn to B6
preparing to F to the light screw bishop
or maybe even going Bishop to A6 uh and
now C captures on D5 we have e captures
and Rook to C1 and now nrec goes back
with the bishop it's a fairly rare move
uh but um uh you know it has been played
before and it has been played by vidit
or rather vidit had the white pieces
against this move uh it was in 2015 it
was the world rapid championship and
vidit played against radoslav tashk and
vidit defeated radoslav in this game by
playing Bishop to D3 but here it's like
it's like VI knew that um Notre backck
prepared maybe for for what vid would
play uh you know according to this game
and he deviates from the bishop to D3
line and he spent some 25 minutes on
this move and he played Pawn to G3 and
it is now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so vid it smells
that something fishy is happening here
Knight B to D7 and now Bishop to G2 and
as soon as vidit moves the Bishop from
this diagonal Norbeck puts his own
Bishop here and controls uh the F1
Square which means vit cannot Castle but
okay Queen to A4 asking Notre backck but
what what is the bishop doing on A6 are
you prepared to play something like
Queen to C8 uh that would just be U
really weird after the Knight comes to
E5 preparing to come to C6 it's just a
terrible terrible Square for your queen
uh but no after Queen to A4 V uh not
plays Bishop to C4 here it's time to
call it the day and bring the bishop
back to B7 just continue the game but he
persists we have Bishop to C4 and now
videt goes into a 15minute thing and he
chases the bishop away further we have
Bishop to D3 and now Knight to E5
forcing a trade of knights as the bishop
on D3 will just hang and you don't
really have squares for the bishop uh
you could put the bishop on F5 but it's
not really a good idea then the Knight
comes to C6 attacks the queen in the
dark Square Bishop so here we have a
trade captures captures and now uh you
are removing the defender of the D5 pawn
and that is a big deal here Knight the
E4 was played and now as you know
telling you that do do you see what vid
it played here and there's one really
really clean way at to uh win material
here even even pause the video you know
it's uh it's a defining moment of the
game uh so yeah so those of you who
found it congratulations on always
looking for a great ways to centralize
your queen and for for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Queen
to D4 and now you're attacking the
bishop once the bishop moves you will
collect the pawn on D5 and Norbeck
really didn't get anything for this uh
Bishop maneuver Bishop to A6 to C4 to to
D3 so okay Knight captures on C3 uh we
have Bishop captures on C3 and now
Bishop back to G6 but now the pawn is
undefended Bishop captures um on D5 puts
pressure on The Rook Pawn to C6 attacks
the bishop and now Bishop back to G2 and
here vidit had some 45 minutes on the
clock notbe had some 35 minutes on the
clock and he doesn't want to trade
Queens he's now down material uh he
wants to activate his pieces but VI it
says Nope Pawn to E6 just threatens
Checkmate and if you block with Bishop
to F6 first of course he will capture on
F7 deliver a check then he will move the
queen and uh well he's happy to to trade
down further so another back tries F6
keeps the pawn on the board but um you
know we'll try to collect it uh
afterwards and now just Queen to D7 by
with it we have Bishop to A3 attacking
The Rook Rook to D1 and now Bishop to F5
uh trying to trade Queens here isn't all
that great just e captures on D7 and
also the C6 Pawn is hanging you're going
to lose that as well you're going to be
down two pawns and lose this game so
instead Notre backck tries Bishop to F5
Queen captures on C6 uh we have uh
Bishop captures on E6 and now Queen
captures on E6 with check it's a
wonderful ATT temp P Queen sacrifice if
you just trade Queens here then Notre
backck is still fine with the two
Bishops you know he will still fight but
now if you make it U uh at this kind of
an end game captur captur and Bishop to
D5 just you know a battle of the two
Bishops of the same color that means
that if you're able to get the Rooks off
the board it will be winning as you are
up a pawn so okay Queen captures on D5
and now Rook captures on D5 so
maximizing your winning opportunity Rook
F to C8 and now King to D2 defending the
bishop and preparing to bring the other
Rook into the game we have Rook to C7
and King to D3 Now situation on the
clock vidit 24 minutes not back some 30
minutes on the clock but vidit is up a
pawn uh so Rook eight to C8 Bishop to D4
uh so keeping your your king safe while
of course um maximizing the the activity
of your pieces King to F7 norbe also
brings the king into the game Rook to D1
indirectly doubling King to E6 we have
Pawn to E4 uh and Rook to C2 going after
some pawns here but uh you can't really
take any of them Rook to D2 just
defending Rook to C1 any and all trades
favor uh vidit as vidit is up in
material we have Pawn to F4 Now The Rook
nicely defends the H2 and A2 pawns you
don't have to worry about them and
Bishop to B4 attacking The Rook we have
Pawn to F5 with check King to E7 and now
Rook to E2 we have Rook to D1 with check
King to E3 and Rook C to
C1 uh Pawn to E5 just breaking through
uh trying to get grab hold of the black
king uh F captures on E5 Rook captures
on E5 with check King F7 and now Pawn to
G4 just marching forward uh Rook back to
C7 and now Rook to E6 we have Rook to D7
and now Bishop to E5 uh Rook to G1 going
after the G4 Pawn King to F3 defending
Rook to D3 with check and now King to F4
and now the Bop to D2 with check and it
Al almost looks like vidit maybe is
becoming too active with his King but
everything works out nicely King to E4
there's no good continuation here you
cannot grab the pawn on G4 because the
Rook on D3 is hanging so Rook back to D7
and now Bishop to G3 just stopping Rook
captur on G4 and there's no way for uh
uh Norbeck to further harass viit King
we have Bishop to B4 uh now comes Rook
to C6 but we have Bishop to C E5 and now
Pawn to G5 and here the problem is uh
even if you try to stop the pawns with
something like G6 then you give up the
F6 Square for your rook and then the
king moves and then you go Bishop to E5
and all sorts of uh problems here even
if you capture one Pawn doesn't really
matter King captures Rook to F1 check
King G4 Rook to G1 check King H5 no more
checks now you have to unpin and now
Rook to C6 and slowly but surely uh this
is um a game over the bishop will come
to F6 the Rooks will occup by the back
Rank and that black king is
doomed so King to f8 was played instead
and now Pawn to
G6 uh sorry Pawn to G6 by by vidit uh H
captures and G6 F captures and now Rook
to E7 with check but Bishop to E5
nothing to worry about here and now you
even have problems of King safety as you
know Rook to C8 check would really ruin
your day so Rook to E8 and now King to
F5 getting closer to the black King Rook
F1 check King to G4 now Rook to G1 check
if uh uh if notbe can prevent vidit from
advancing further then his chances for a
draw are are some somewhat existent but
it's going to be very hard King to H5
Bishop to E7 uh looks very nice and
especially now after Pawn to H4 if you
can somehow uh win that H4 Pawn it's
going to be Checkmate imagine this
position this is a very nice Checkmate
uh but after Rook to H1 of course Bishop
to G3 just defend there's no way that
will happen so Rook to d8 now Rook C to
E6 putting pressure on the bishop Bishop
to C5 and now Bishop to C7 trying to
kick away The Rook from the back rank to
deliver this Checkmate uh Rook to C8 and
now Bishop back to F4 we have Rook to
D1 uh and Rook two to E4 uh Pawn to A5
and now King to G4 uh we have Rook to G1
with check King to F5 and Rook to d8 so
norbec says all right I'm just going to
going to move my Rook back and forth uh
there's no real way for you to get grab
hold of the back rank uh but now Bishop
to G5 takes away one more Square from
The Rook we have Rook to F1 with check
uh King to G4 Rook to G1 check King to
H5 now Rook to C8 and now Rook to C4 so
now also preventing the Bishop from
moving you can't go here with the Rook
you can't go here you have the B8 and A8
Square so Rook to A8 is played and now
Rook to F4 with check forcing the king
to the G file now Rook F to E4 trying to
go for Rook to E8 check to get one of
the Rooks off the board like we said all
material trades favor viit as he is up
in material uh Rook to f8 and there's
now no more way to stop that Rook to E2
is play to well make the the A2 Pawn a
little bit safer but after Rook G to F1
just Rook to E8 it's time to go trading
uh we have Bishop to B4 Rook captures
King captures and now Rook to C2 we have
Bishop to C5 trying to stop The Rook
from infiltrating King to G4 Rook G1
check King to F1 King to F5 Rook to F1
with check King to E6 now King to E8 and
now Rook to E2 stopping all checks uh
and saying now it's time to to finish
the game Rook to G1 uh Rook to E5 and
now King to f8 uh Rook to D5 going for
checkmate here so Rook to E1 with check
and here King to F5 was played any he
was in this position un move 77 that
notb abdat resigned the game uh as there
is nothing more to be done here it is
his first loss of the tournament but he
does
suffer uh a loss and the vidit is still
undefeated going into the final round of
the Tata still 2024 uh alongside
prananda who almost suffered defeat at
hands of GES but uh it seems that for
the moment Prague is Immortal uh and
here you resign uh well what can you
play if if you try Bishop B7 we said
that all trades of course favor wide
just captures and after let's say
captures Rook E5 check uh forces a king
and pawn end game you're up a pawn of
course King and pawn end games are
winning if you're up a pawn and if you
try something else let's say you try
Rook to F1 with check it's not going to
work you're going to go King E6 Rook E1
check King to D7 and now okay you you
can stop uh the the Checkmate as the the
king is now in the way but it's not a
problem King C7 you go after the pawns
and after Bishop to
C5 uh now uh you you go for the check
Rook to d8 with check uh Rook to E8 only
move and now you don't even have to
trade Pawn to A4 and after Bishop to F2
you will first improve the position go
after the Rook now a trade is imminent
captures captures uh and now after
Bishop to C5 you will go Pawn to H5
after Bishop to F2 now you finally put
the King on C6 you start capturing and
that's it you're up too much material so
brilliant stuff by vit and uh it all
came down to this uh moment where where
Notre Beck tried to uh tried to activate
this bishop on this diagonal if this was
was yeah I mean if it was good everyone
would play it it's just not good and um
I know when I played the Nimo or the
ragozin I the the mood that I hate
seeing the most is Queen to A4
regardless where where I put my Bishop
uh but Queen to A4 is just a just a
powerful moving these lines and uh yeah
here the bishop should have retreated to
B7 but you know he went on to look for
adventure and Adventure he most
certainly did find now regarding the the
other results of the round um I'm just
going to share them with you here so
these are the results donchenko and
param Drew their game ala defeated Yan
pish you've seen that in the previous
video Jordan blundered terribly against
Tanish giri V defeated NRE abov guesh
and PR that Drew their game Jun lost to
Wei also a brilliant game probably we'll
show that one after the tournament is
over uh I mean pretty much every we is
Worth showing in this event and dingen
defeated Max vam so a bit of a Comfort
win for the world champion dealing Max
his fourth loss in a row so tough break
for Max and also here are the standings
going into the final round we have uh
not one not two not three not four but
five way ties seven and a half points
for vidit Anish GES not and we and I
mean it's so hard to say who is still
able to win the tournament probably I
mean of course they can ala and prar on
seven points can also win uh but um you
know uh from that point on uh nepo on
six cannot win dingan on 5 and a half
cannot win Alexander donchenko and Bam
makulu on 4 and a half we have Max Mar
Jordan F forest and J Wun on Four Points
so it's going to be a wild first last
round remember last round always starts
a little an hour sooner than all of the
other rounds if you are you know
preparing to follow it live so yeah
we'll see what happens I will try to
cover it um as extensively as possible
and then as usual after a big tournament
you guys can suggest games that I've
missed if they are worthy of showing I
will very very happily show them but
yeah brilliant stuff by vidit you cannot
you cannot touch him he is so strong you
know he just meditates before the game
and uh you know finds these intricacies
and he he just crushes you doesn't
matter who you are even if you are as
strong as NRE Abdus satov so that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Lana is the best wife in
the world Sam Kane ghard hlan Hans
Anderson and David gasparian for a
contribution to my channel Channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day